[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
est ce un tronc déformés ou un homme
métamorphosé dans cette exposition comme
dans la forêt l'on trouve des faits des
sorcières bref des créatures étranges
en tout sept tableaux inspirés de contes
romantiques du 19e siècle nous rappelle
la place de la forêt comme ici dans
l'histoire de la belle et la bête
nous sommes au début du bang et lorsque
la bête veut charmer la belle en
déployant un banquet de richesse de
préciosité tout à fait sublime dans ce
palais endormi un petit peu en goûter où
la forêt a repris ses droits sur le
château une forêt fascinante
inquiétantes aussi comme lorsqu elle
abrite le mythe des willis ces femmes
est conduite sur l'autel condamné à
danser pour l'éternité un univers
fantastique dans lequel le visiteur est
plongé au travers d'un jeu de lumière et
de sous
l'idée est en effet de transporter le
visiteur donc la mise en ambiance et est
très importante
on est sur des teintes en effet du gris
du blanc des matières très très éthéré
il ya aussi une bande sonore
voilà a fait de fait de souffle de de
bruissements d'arbres dans chacun des
tableaux présentés la mise en scène ne
fait que s'inspirer des comptes pour
attiser l'imagination là celui de
dentelle au pied d'un arbre évoque la
belle au bois dormant mais fait écho à
tant d'autres récits qui pense à ces
chevaliers qui vont se perdre dans la
forêt et rencontrer des créatures
fantastiques pensons aussi au petit
poucet qui est perdu dans la forêt donc
voilà la forêt et cet endroit où où l'on
se perd cet endroit mystérieux sans fin
un endroit mystérieux où les reflets et
les bruits nous joue des tours
au point de regarder les arbres
différemment à la sortie du château